piano via okay quello gioca dei chi
cazzo giochi adult che mi distrae lai
l'ho neanche mai niente giacché salto
della madonna va bene allora dico altro
dico salto di questo sì sì sì no no no
sì sì no kat affanculo [ __ ] è
caduto tutto è crollato il mouse
perfetto chi annego i pesci
no no cannes ignota ladra [ __ ]
sporca ma come come la torta di me ma
mica un coltello mi serve nella torta su
vuol dire su no vuol dire tua mamma vuol
dire subito ne vado su su toni money
money money money money money numeri
numeri numeri madonna la propaggine
[Musica]
madonna concluso salvato madonna madonna
no
[Musica]
per questo nuovo saltare non mi incazzo
cazzo vai vai veloce
[Risate]
sì io mio dio mio
cosa è successo è successo c'è cara
delle vinci ho cercato cala delle vigne
l'altro giorno è bella è una donna bella
ma chi è che inventò si cazzo di diversi
sarà qualcuno lavori che ragazzi ho
provato a recuperare la coca cola la
terra e questo è stato il risultato sono
morto non sono anche come sono morto
lega non sono anche come sono morto dio
santo no [ __ ] timori se il pesce
si cosa da fare quando non si sa che
cazzo fare ok
cosa cazzo ha fatto
briga rega sa che sto facendo io non
sono mai arrivato fin qua giù l'ho mai a
caso no no [ __ ] tuoi triangolini
di merda sono morto cioè mangiano un
infarto no ma [ __ ]
oddio cos'è avevo visto la lama che
grossa quanto mia nonna che non l'ho
vista lo sapevo no no cielo quasi
non è possibile non è così e non è
possibile christian ma come fai a fare
ma ammetto in un cazzo dice che poi no
no a questa stoffa calmo stai calmo stai
calmo stai calmo e checa calmissimo è
caldissimo e subito benissimo la madonna
sì sì sì sì sì sì no no kat
mio dio che gioca brutto no no no ma per
che cosa è successo dieci ragioni per
cui abbiamo sempre fame è a me che cazzo
me ne frego
sì sì sì già fatta arriva altro perché
ha preparati
vuoi che faccia di merda poi all ici
salto sopra vedi queste infilo tutti e
due non ci tornerò mai più qui quindi se
vinco vinco non ce n'è
[Musica]
buzzi no no no no no no ho vinto
l'analoga se ci riesco ad occhi chiusi è
impossibile non ci prova qualche a [ __ ]
che ti mollo ma che è meglio giocare con
questo quadrato che esalta gli ostacoli
di lato ma sto gioco poi chi se lo
piglia
se tu perdi ti ammazzo la famiglia si ok
ragazzi no no no mi si sono invertiti i
tasti di nuovo tua sorella vende gelati
no no no no si può non messo quattro
aree a parlare di te ho messo quattro
ore niente niente
[Musica]
cosa ho aperto
no no no no si gode godo oddio oddio
[Musica]
cazzo ma dai forza forza
sì sì
sì aiuto oddio porca [ __ ] c'è cosa
stavo facendo adottare un bambino quanto
d'oro questi livelli non mi si incrocia
al cervello di più ma sempre lì
non disturbiamo sua mamma facciamo le
cose per bene non va più il tasto a
destra lo sto premendo non va più cristo
gesù noi abbiamo tutto il gioco che è
crashato perché ovviamente sono uscito
ma non importa perché tanto sono al
punto di partenza ho iniziato 40 minuti
fa sono ancora quattro super tua madre
già faccio madonna caso mattino ci credo
fermi un attimo mi sta salendo
l'adrenalina una maniera incredibile mi
sta salendo la telecamera e rozzi sì
[Musica]